hey everyone we're gonna be doing
something a little different this week
I've got Maajid Nawaz jumping on a Skype
call shortly he and Sam Harris are
co-authors of a new book about Islam and
Majid is a former Islamic extremist
himself a ton of you guys have been
asking us to sit down but he lives in
London so we thought we'd give the Skype
thing a shot actually he's in New York
at the moment I saw a picture of him and
Morgan Freeman in a mosque yesterday so
I'm gonna ask him about that and much
more in a little bit but first let's do
a little housekeeping I want to talk
about some of the principles we laid out
in the first episode and some of the
reaction to last week's show it seems
that a bunch of you weren't thrilled
with my guest Jimmy door Jimmy is a
hardcore lefty progressive and uses some
of the tactics I mentioned that I
wouldn't be using on the show first let
me just say that I can only hold myself
to the rules that I laid out if I
stopped and mention saying every time a
guest said saying that goes against my
personal rules the show would be
incredibly slow and horrific ly painful
more importantly as we build a community
based on tolerance and other ideas it's
important that we remain tolerant of
ideas we don't like Jimmy is a great
friend of mine we've worked together on
air for years we've done stand-up gigs
together and I've had him and his wife
over for dinner numerous times yeah we
don't agree on everything including some
pretty big issues but I think life is
about more than just scoring who is
right on everything all the time the
most interesting part of last week's
response was that some people said the
episode was an echo chamber and I didn't
push back enough other people questioned
why I even had people I disagree with on
at all and that's the beauty of the
internet right we can all be part of the
same exact conversation and still see it
through our individual prisms good
journalism is the search for truth this
show will be a battle of ideas not just
having our own ideas reinforced you know
there's so much intolerance of the other
on both sides and I think we can create
something that's so much better than
that actually I don't just think it I
know it because I see it already
happening last week I had a hardcore
progressive lefty this week I have a
former Islamist extremists turned
moderate trying to reform his religion
next week I have a gay conservative from
Breitbart meelo yin applets I won't
agree with all of them all the time but
I most likely won't shout them down
either I have enough faith in you guys
that if we have an honest conversation
here the truth will present itself
this of course reminds me of the
Galactic Republic in the
early days of the Deathstar grand moff
tarkin wanted to stifle debate because
they had the most powerful super laser
in the universe of course let's not
forget that Darth Vader said that the
Death Star was nothing compared to the
power of the force the force is on our
side let's use it wisely